Sáng nay ngày 3,5 người năm 2018, bắn phòng cửa quang kể rất đều trạc quan tình
dễ lại đã làm việc bắn độ với tẻ CTVC, sinh 5,5 chiến trăm sống mi tạm.
Chú sạy ý phi, ra lại, người vây ra vụ tên ảnh khiến một người từ bóng trên đường vui chiming,
đoạn qua địa bản sá mình hồ, sau đó bỏ chốn.
Chứ đó, khoảng 18 giờ chiến phút hồn qua ông C điều khiến tụ tổ tảm mi mốt a 2 sau tám không bà,
đưa thông trên đường vui chiming, hướng từ sá chiều 8 đi 3 đi 4.
Đi đoạn qua thương bệnh, 3 đi đoạn hồ, ông C đã tông vào xem may só chiến đo tê,
sinh 5,5 chiến trăm tảm mi sấu, chú xá mình hồ, đưa khiến cùng chù phi trước.
Đưa tốt khiến chỉ tế cùng xem may bị hất phong hơn mấy mết và chẳng với xem may của ông Cà,
sống mi sấu tuổi, chú xá mình hồ, đi theo rứng hột lại.
Chị tế từ phông trên đường đưa đi cấp thử, ông Cà được xuất hiện ngày sau đó vì xức hệ uống định.
Sau tay nạn, ông Cà tăng gà bỏ trẻ,
công an sạm biến hồ vui hồ, với đưa kảnh sát xa thông đường bộ xu hai,
phong kảnh sát xa thông, công an tình đã nhé trong chuyến với phở li lạc với ông Cà,
đến tôi qua ông Cà đã đến cơ quan công an chính dịch.
Tại đây, qua chim chà, cơ quan công an xa đi, ông Cà cũng độ cùng khu vỷ không hai xấu mi đi gà một lý tí thử,
hình vụ việc tiếp tục đuổi chà làm só.